[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: In Google
Kubernetes Engine,
our GKE's Cluster
Autoscaler feature
enables clusters to
automatically resize
the number of nodes
in a node pool
without manual intervention
based on your workload demands.
The autoscaler triggers
the node scale-up events
when there are unscheduable pods
and node scale-down events when
there are underutilized nodes.
The autoscaler prints
any scaling decisions
made to increase or decrease
the size of the node pool,
any errors that occurred
during the scaling process, et
cetera, as events or
entries in Cloud Logging.
The Cluster Autoscaler
logs can help
in investigating any
issues with autoscaling.
In this video, we
will look at how
to view the Cluster
Autoscaler logs, including
how to troubleshoot and resolve
one of the events observed
in the log.
First, we will learn how to view
the Cluster Autoscaler logs.
In the Google Cloud console,
go to the Logs Explorer page.
From the Resources
dropdown list,
select Kubernetes Cluster, then
select the location and name
of your cluster.
From the Log Name
dropdown list, select
container.googleapis.com/cluster
autoscaler visibility.
From the Time Range dropdown
list, select a time range.
In our cluster, we'll view
the logs for the last hour.
Cluster Autoscaler
events may also
show up as notifications in
the Google Cloud Console user
interface.
Notifications can
help you monitor
scaling events in the cluster
and act on them if needed.
Oh, there's indeed a
notification in our cluster
which states that the Cluster
Autoscaler can't scale-up nodes
because node
auto-provisioning is disabled.
The Details section
below the notification
may have some additional
information about the event.
If you click on Logs, it will
take you to the Logs Explorer
page directly.
Now, let us look at the node
scale-up event, which is one
of the most common event types.
A node scale-up event is logged
if the autoscaler cannot scale
the cluster any further.
This happens if there
are unscheduable pods
in the cluster and the
autoscaler cannot scale
the cluster up to
accommodate them.
You can refer to the
fields, like reason
and napFailureReason, to
understand why scale-up failed.
The reason field
provides information
on why the Cluster
Autoscaler is prevented
from scaling up the nodes.
For a cluster, the reason field
has the value "max node group
size reached."
This indicates that the Cluster
Autoscaler could not scale up
because the maximum node
size for the node pool
has been reached.
Hence, no more
nodes can be added.
The napFailureReason
field provides information
on what prevented the Cluster
Autoscaler from provisioning
additional node pools.
For our cluster, this
field is populated
with value
"no.scale.up.nap.disabled,"
which means that node
auto-provisioning did not
provision any new node groups
because node auto-provisioning
is disabled.
To solve this problem, we can
either increase the max size
limit for autoscaling
for the node pool
or enable node auto-provisioning
for the cluster.
Check out the
documentation to see more
about reviewing Cluster
Autoscaler events
and understanding the
different reasons for the same.
[MUSIC PLAYING]